Carlsberg is a name most often
associated with a best-selling beer from
Denmark so the obvious next step in
brand expansion was to move into Shaving
and skincare products hipsters queue up
at Carl's barber shop in Copenhagen to
have hops yeast and barley work they're
beautifying magic on their facial hair
beard beauty and as the marketing
campaign calls it with a little bit of
fantasy it smells like beer I almost
feel like like tasting it definitely the
best smelling foam I ever experienced
Carlsberg and beer sure but why male
grooming products Carlsberg started
brewing in 1847 and is now one of the
largest beer producers on earth
cosmetics was not an obvious choice or
was it
we have some quality ingredients in the
beer that are natural and that can be
conveyed into the cosmetics industry and
have good benefits for the skin it is
more to convey some very good
interesting story and taking the quality
that you have in your beer product and
applying that to another category and in
fact it all seems pretty straightforward
hops barley and yeast usually used in
brewing beer are freeze-dried at the
Carlsberg laboratory in Copenhagen with
the resulting powder than being combined
with organic cosmetic essences when a
company branches into new markets it's
called brand extension or brand
stretching it's easier and cheaper to
stretch a famous brand like oz bag than
to create an entirely new brand virgin
started out as a record store chain but
now runs an airline and financial
services under the same logo and from a
little blue tin of skin cream
Nivea built arranged spanning all manner
of body care products it's a phenomenon
that marketing expert who Baptists fund
lobenstein has been following for years
among the companies he's analyzed as
apple and its success in computers
mobile phones and watches brands story
the brand's story they developed was
viable enough to be transplanted to
other segments Apple never simply said
we're going to make computers Apple said
we are the brand that supports people
who think in new ways the others think
but customers have discriminating tastes
when it comes to food and beverage Swiss
company Maggi is a famous maker of
noodles and instant soups but it's sweet
ketchup was a commercial flop maybe a
toothpaste
likewise bombed when fast-food giant
McDonald's decided to start its own
hotel chain the public found them
unappetizing
one of the more predictable flops was
motorcycle maker Harley Davidsons
venture into children's clothing
subsistent he is he the market demon oh
I need a file brand extensions always
have their risks of course if I'm
seriously far off the mark in my act on
the parent brand - it's entirely
possible to destroy the original brand
and its story with extensions the Kyle's
bag marketing team had to find a way of
getting the right message across
until now Kyle's barracks brand story
has essentially portrayed men mastering
life's challenges with the help of all
empowering beer via here fella didn't
believe in Smith beer producers
reference lifestyle if you drink this
you're a cool dude you'll be a hit with
the ladies you have to transport the
world the brand represents to make it
believable so it's a daring move because
it's so out of left field but as Z as if
I'd also woods whether the shaving
products will go down as well as the
brew will also depend on those ladies we
took a little survey on the streets of
Copenhagen
fancy a man with a beard smelling of
beer
when cars break in his face I don't know
yeah we used to sex seems on my well not
really even know the morning-after can
appear that's awful but this is nice but
customers at Carl's barbershop seem
confident about the benefits of hops
barley and yeast and surely they know
best